[Music]
hello everybody thank you so much for
joining us for this wonderful bafta q a
uh with well you can see who's here
we've got tony we've got joe hartley and
mr ricky device thank you so much for
joining us folks great to have you
and first of all congratulations guys on
this second series of afterlife it's
brilliant so you're going to be happy
with the response that it's had so far i
mean literally as it kind of was
unveiled it was instant wasn't it
yeah well i mean i've never had a
response like
on the first season but of course
because it's always there that sort of
grew so it was going up through the
whole
year so i guess what's happened is all
those people that watched the first
series and loved it watched this series
straight away
so it's absolutely mental i mean like
tens of thousands of tweets that i'm
trying to you know
like them to know that i've read them or
and i i i try and
you know retweet the the odd one but i
mean
yeah it's it's crazy it it it's it's
phenomenal and and yeah lovely really
lovely because people still don't need
to bother
it's only a tweet but they don't need to
i don't i do it rarely
i've decided i'm going to start doing it
i just started randomly saying nice
things about bbs days i just thought
i'm getting all these praise so i just
said like you know what i mean
i i like richard osmond not pointless i
think it's brilliant so i just died
oh my tony and joe gets in just one
second but ricky
did you write series two had series one
already
and been released and had you had a
reaction to before you started writing
the second series or yeah i
i had some ideas for season two as it
came out but then you do
and mostly you you try and you try and
do it your own way and you don't
second-guess people because you'll get
it wrong
um the one thing i did incorporate
um is that i realized that
it was the emotional reaction that was
the most
incredible and that people would come up
to me and say oh i lost my brother three
weeks before
or and it helped me or i lost my wife a
year ago and i realized that everyone
was grieving
and they they loved seeing that done
in a in a comedy a dark comedy or but
they liked
seeing that recognized it and i felt a
responsibility to treat it correctly so
i didn't have him just get better and
snap out of it i
i i really incorporated the fact that it
takes a long time and he is breathing
he's going through
depression and anxiety and all those
things
right that that that sliding scale of
mental illness
and he's going through it all so i i
thought
i would explore that more and not just
have him go anyway i feel better now
i've got a nurse
so do you know what i mean it's like
my mate i'm christopher guest who you
know um
uh he told me once um
the director of uh rain man told him you
know
they do those audience things when they
they say what would you change about
this what did you like what did you like
and uh he's got this one framed and it's
someone saying
i really enjoyed the film but i was
hoping the little guy
would snap out of it by the end so
so that's some people they want a happy
ending but it's yeah
it's not you know it's not always there
and
tony it's it's it's wonderful to watch
this um
you know all these characters and uh and
as i was
speaking to ricky about this actually
last week was that what's brilliant
about the way that it's written is that
all these characters we get to know a
bit better and a bit more
in this series as well and and lenny's
one of these characters that
you know whenever you're on screen
particularly you know when it's when
it's
outside of the relationship that he has
with tony and stuff we get to know more
about them
and when it's given to you in terms of a
script and you see a script for the
first time
how much of it do you think is a
reaction to kind of how you've brought
that character to life and how you
collaborate on set with you know where
the character's been already to where
he's going
well i think um we did work
shopping although it wasn't really a
workshop we would have coffees and
a lunch and a chat um a few times
throughout the year when
in the when ricky was writing the first
series and i think
we weren't really sort of coming up with
stuff or writing stuff but ricky was
definitely
watching us do his stuff and sort of
then
thinking oh that's good that bit was
funny that wasn't and sort of
working sort of writing the script on
its feet really
but this series i think definitely
ricky had noticed that me and um
that lenny and june were a thing and he
from the
the first day that joe came in there was
clearly
there had to be more of her and more of
me coming here
and that's sort of then what do you do
that he and uh
he and lenny get together and i think
that definitely ricky i'm sure will
correct me but i think that definitely
came from
the day that joe came in and was so
brilliant
oh absolutely and also everything
counts i do i do work with people i like
working with
you know it's not like it's not if if
someone was an absolute [ __ ] and they
were a popular character
they'd be written out you know what i
mean it's like
of course you go i want to work with one
more event and
uh you can get the best of both worlds
you can work with really nice people
who are brilliant actors and come up
with stuff
and and that's why i work with the same
people all the time because
there's not many you know and i've and
um i
uh it's an absolute joy to work with
these people and i i do want to mean
everything i do
and as much as some the plot can
you know take so uh yeah absolutely i
i put in physicalities of people and
that's the beauty of knowing who you're
writing for i cast this before i'd
written it
because i knew well if yeah before i'd
written anything
the first idea was the wife i called
carrie i said you want to be my dead
wife
at first she said she thought am i
playing a corpse i went no no no
i'll explain and then you know you you
you go through
yeah everybody um
you called me for the very first meeting
first tentative meeting after you that
there might be a part for me
so i was sort of half treating it as a
casting and i remember it in your office
and there's four flights of stairs
and i got to the bottom of the i thought
they were only going to be two
and i went oh my god and i heard you
laughing and great perfect that's
it that's right yeah i did again i did
yeah i thought that's funny
he's gonna be a slob he's gonna be out
of breath but
what i liked about the lenny character
he's one of those people that's
imperative you can insult him
doesn't matter you got snacks by the bed
yep
he is he's happy with his life he's
happy with everything he's got
i'm jealous of people like lenny because
that you can't you can't hurt their feet
they're great they're brilliant
and then and then obviously joe's
character is very similar she's just so
kind a bit dim but
what is it like on on set and what's it
like to then kind of you know
to kind of pop up as a character and
then that character being been given a
whole kind of storyline and to be kind
of part of that
that narrative as well and and and also
collaborate on set
as well i mean it's amazing on set
it's like there's an energy so you kind
of there's lots of love on that set
lots of laughter nobody's taking
themselves too seriously but the job is
serious
like we want to find it it's beautiful i
mean i was coming home one friday night
and i had a bit of a bad day and i got
text a little message on fricking he
said if you got that this was
afterlife one of you got the scripts i
was like what no
and i was gonna tell you i said no and
he said oh i've written this little
cameo for you do you want to be in the
show and i was
i was going to text back and say really
busy at the moment mate can't fit you in
and i thought no he might not get it you
might just
it might be like oh okay i just took the
bag and was like yeah
and then i remember going in for a
couple of days i was in a couple of
episodes
and i just had the best fun in that
scene where we talked about cream eggs
and little fat we all seem naked in the
bath and all that
and it was just so much fun and i got to
do a little bit of improv
with ricky and and you know tony and
that and then
i got a lovely text on the way i'm
saying great well done and it just
slipped me up you know
i was buzzing so when uh ricky said
we're doing it again i think tony and i
was at the screen and they said i've got
an idea for you too
and um it just kind of went from there
and then i was invited in to do
sort of you know rehearsals and but it's
very
collaborative and ricky's very generous
i mean we all
kind of i remember him emailing me the
the monologue that i do to the
receptionist and i spat my tea out
because i
he must have just watched us all day we
were talking about all sorts of things
i remember going and thinking well
there's not much in this episode for me
and
i thought ricky just feels sorry for me
it's just it's just getting me in
because he feels sorry
because i trust you honestly you're one
you're one of the best improviser you
are one of the best improvisers i
discovered you
from uh your for the improv movie this
is england and i just thought
when i discovered that was just all
improv i just felt like i'm having that
that's that's yeah no it was brilliant
and i think that's what
um we all find really fun is like it's
very organic
but ricky then will he don't really miss
a trick do you it's like he'll go away
and write
things and i think my friend who i was
on the phone to today in new york
she said something to me maria she said
there's a
there's something that you say and she
said wow it was like
i thought you might have improvised i
said no ricky wrote that she said well
he must really know you quite well i
think
i can't remember the line now but it was
like
it's great to work with people who care
who listen
who really value you and also then you
don't have to be in every single scene
trying to do everything which i've never
really had to do but
just to be a part of something so
magical i feel like i've actually fallen
in love with the show
and it's really really powerful you know
it's um
it's a funny time of my life where i
feel so grateful to be alive and
this is this is amazing for me so i'm
just grateful to be there it's lovely
yeah i love them all i'm gonna cry joe's
gonna cry again that's exactly what i
was gonna say i'm gonna cry again
bless you but it's that thing as well
because you you know
you write it you direct it and you know
and and you play tony but
but you write all these brilliant
characters and stories for these
characters and it must be
really hard to almost hold back because
as you say you've got this incredible
collection of people
who bring these characters to life so it
must be almost kind of hard knowing
not to just give them more in a way do
you know
the thing is um these episodes
uh they come in at 45 minutes
and i don't even have to cut them
because it's netflix but it'll be flabby
so i used to get depressed when i used
to have to cut
15 minutes out of a episode and now i
realize
that just make it's brilliant that's so
good the bit that's left is amazing
so um yeah we always
you write too much you film too much and
then you just
keep honing it down to it and you'll
you'll be amazed what you can get rid of
and not lose anything as well
and often the things that are on the
cutting room
floor are the funniest things on the day
the crew are laughing
everyone's laughing you can't get
through it they're funny but
sometimes they don't drive the plot and
sometimes it's because
the crew haven't heard it before because
it's important and in the cold light of
day
the things that were of uh mostly 90
i'd say are the written screenplay bits
that were filmed done properly every
angle's cut
that drive the plot and then then you
get something like david earl
who just says just goes for it and you
just pick a nugget you go
we have that that's the thing and then
everyone looks it you know
there even know that it's gonna make up
i'd say 50
of the uptakes you know but
the bits that are left just and you can
have too much
it's like you couldn't watch seinfeld if
it was half an hour of kramer you just
go
okay that's enough too much so that
you you know what i mean you yeah you
need all these ordinary people
that are doing audrey things and saying
sensible things
you know it's a you you do
need all those people around to make
david o look crazy and funny
but you do need matt at the map in it
and you do need sandy and you do
need you need all those people um uh
otherwise it's there's no reason to
watch it it's like watching
a hundred puns you can be laughing but
you're looking at your watch after
twenty
where as the comedian comes out and
tells you what a bad day they've had
you're riveted you've got it's a story
that's the important thing
it's a story and i think as well it's
that
and the connection the response you're
getting is because you're writing
stories about real people and real
situations and that's why
people are connecting so much with it
and you're getting the response
you know from people sending you
messages about their own loss and their
own
you know where they're dealing with
grief and and i think that's and that
doesn't just relate to tony's story i
think that's what's brilliant about this
series and all the different characters
there's even more to relate to well
that's why
i'm i'm uh i'm fascinated with um
realism i've always i think it resonates
more
and also i think what people recognize
they don't even know it if you can get
how people
feel about summer you've won because
they don't know how
you've done it you know people go oh i
like the postman because i'm a postman
or i work in an office or i was an actor
but it doesn't resonate
whereas if you do oh my god that was me
that's how i acted when so and so
i think like that every day oh my god
that's that's even
bigger so you what you're trying to do
with this my own
is to download emotions make them feel
something even if they don't
if they're not just laughing at a
one-liner or
scared of something or you don't need
car crashes
sometimes people are watching it like
that
just thinking about stuff and that's and
that's enough
then and then at the end they go oh that
was amazing
you know it's it he doesn't need these
uh bombastic you you know
you don't need to tell people how to
feel they just do
they just do yeah um
joe and tony in particular i mean
there's there's a brilliant i mean the
the
the bedroom scene is she is just
hilarious um and
i mean i don't really know what to ask
about it but it's just
it's yeah well the funny thing was about
that is
it didn't really drive the plot which
you know it was to show how awkward it
was it was to show
how awkward how mad this family is that
tony got himself into
he'd given his flat away to matt he got
his
what he calls his back steps on a job
and it was clean
what have i done and so it was that and
it could have gone but it was just so
funny and angsty that i just thought i'd
just put it i just throw it i just throw
it in
i'll just throw it in at the end before
the sad scene um
and uh uh honestly
it was just when the light goes on just
the light goes on
it's going have you seen my juggles and
paws yeah
the thing there as well is i was like
before that scene i was like right
just don't don't don't try to be funny
just do it and keep
normal and it was like it's when she
sort of reacts as if he's just like
chatting to her about what's in the new
you know it's just like yeah
yeah well they're just downstairs anyway
busy at the minute but
i've seen him at darling it's like very
kind of like
normal for them the magic love love
and that's why it's funny because
actually the only normal person in it
is lenny he's reacting right he's going
he's the audience going
this is mental i'm having sex and her
kids come in to ask each other that's
mental and he's stunned and what's funny
is you two
you two acting like it's if all three of
you acted like there was nothing wrong
with it it wouldn't be
you'd be odd it would just be a surreal
world but the fact there's someone there
going this is mental
amazing well he won't he won't leave
because he likes cream eggs
yeah and there's also something i i put
something a little bit eatable in there
that he
he wants to hug his mum and then he
asked lenny can i call you dab and so
you know there's really something
missing
in this kid's life right so even though
it's all funny and mental
and all that actually when it comes out
that
and again it's still a comedy scene but
when you're saying
that um you know you have to choose one
of them for the managed to work
you chose him no not at first i chose
his dad but you know
and then you realize this kid has gone
through an awful lot and it's why
it's it's the reason he is like he is
it's the reason he wants
sorry one of my favorite directions on
that scene as well was
not i don't think it's written that it
happened but you said when the door
closes and he's gone
carry on yeah
it was so funny because people have been
tweeting about the noise and the
i was like god we thought that one might
just slip slip under the radar with
everything else that's going on but
it was really fun and we had such a
laugh i think we was all a bit
embarrassed but it was good fun
and then if it was real think about
i mean
i know just out of the question a comedy
one's fine everyone's dress
is just it's silly but a real one for
absolutely not he was the most
embarrassed person there that day i
think so i was gonna say on set that
morning everyone was just like
oh yeah i wouldn't come everyone was
just like full of energy it was like
right let's do this and it was so funny
it was kind of in the middle of a studio
as well so it's just like a little stage
in the middle of nowhere it's like well
is this my job this is my job okay let's
do this
yeah but yeah think how
think how a million times worse
a real one is with the crew watching
it's just out of the question
it's not the question what's the young
lad who plays is it
ethan lawrence who plays your your son
as well
amazing brilliant brilliant yeah right
around the whole variety performance
um as well and and oh that that the kind
of
uh yeah the town hall was just
extraordinary i wanted to do
i wanted to create something that i'd
love to go to if i was
if i was in a you know a little village
for a weekend and then
it had um ammo tonight i'd go to jail
we're going
front seat here right come on right
because also i want to be that it's it's
bad but that's good
it's it i hate it when you're doing
karaoke and someone
jumps up and they're like they're aretha
franklin well that's the end of the
night
yeah that's that's the end yeah you know
it's like
it's i love these floors i love this
fact that
it is it is all a bit crap we're all a
bit crap
that's good that's that's crap that's
funny yeah
it's exactly there's nothing there's
nothing amusing about being perfect
it's like there's nothing funny about
those people on instagram with their abs
and the boat they pretended theirs it's
like
what is yes i want to see a pa i want
tony just um tweets pictures of me what
he's eating
now that is funny
you know the end all the the kind of the
other the other side of things that's
going on with with tony and lisa that
he's watching as
you know as we watch through the series
do you film all that beforehand before
you then
film throughout whenever you know
because it's about availability and
obviously
um all the ones in the house have got to
be done when we're in the house and all
the ones in location so we're doing what
through
um uh but they're a joy as well when you
just do
it too much is real and kerry is just
brilliant improv as well she's so real
she's so real all the time most of the
things
apart from the fact that we planned the
location and what we're doing
i think nearly all kerry's dialogue is
improv the bit where she's playing with
the dog and she goes
that was just going what get your deal
don't brandy and i really laughed out
loud
because it was an improv so um and what
we found is
in the first season and the second is
that
the more fun the flashbacks are with me
and lisa
the sadder it is absolutely so
the joy at the wedding cut into me
watching it
oh my god it's just it makes it so much
sadder so
yeah i've noticed those this time i've
noticed some of those flashbacks and how
amazing kerry is actually and
like when she's jumping or you're
putting water on her or like in the
first one just
all those are just so beautiful and
she's so reactive like
when when the first one i think is when
you put water on her in the deck chair
and she's like ah and it's like
how do you do that on your own you know
it's great it's new but just a brilliant
action like brilliant it's just
brilliant so real and the fact that she
gives you an odd time and all that it's
great
it's really yeah we wanted it to be real
as well we didn't want it to be like an
80s coffee advert we didn't want to be
like this fake romance
we want to be real good thing around
that's what we're doing that like you
know
with me balancing her i do that with
jane and if
me and jane are doing stuff really
stupid i go oh
i should put that in afterlife and jane
goes poor kerry
oh my god that's amazing and i love as
well it's all those moments where
you know tony and larry are going out to
do the story coverage and and
you know do their little bit on all
these little stories for the paper it's
just
you know and that's the thing as well
it's like when you're when you're
working out what those are going to be
what are you know are those coming from
real
things you've read yeah people think
that that's that like the surreal bit
and i don't know they're based on all
true stories all those things
the guy posted the letter i saw that and
the uh
the um uh vaginal yeast making bread saw
that in a magazine
yeah um the
the uh rice pudding that breast milk
that happened to a friend of mine
someone a neighbor came round and said
i've over uh made this
uh wow the streams all the stains that
comes by the stains
i thought it'd be funny that you know
it's usually jesus but i thought i'd
make it you know
and then because you know the joke is
that well any stain looks like kenneth
branagh he's got no
so then you do they add the comedy to it
the argument
that you get into the real life of those
people but they're all
they're they either did or could happen
in in local papers or real papers
you know yeah um and i did go down to
like you know crazy headlines and now
some of them are things like the front
cover of some local papers i've seen i
saw one
um uh man finds hat in tree
that was okay
[Music]
oh no here's some of my favorite bits to
film
because um you get some amazing guests
in for that as well yeah that's when you
can do sneaky cameos when you can give
someone a really meaty
uh a scene-stealing part
and that is just one day like holly
dempsey is the
uh the thing that's gotten gone wrong
um steve spears is the man posting i
mean incredible
uh yeah uh oh annette crosby absolute
national treasure 86 years old i think
five c
words in the first two minutes i mean
talk about scene stealing as well and
penelope wilton
um i mean yeah
um i mean yeah i kind of i kind of want
an on spin-off show to be honest it's
well everyone wants everyone wants to
know all of them
like her she's she's everything she's
you know
she's maternal she's wise she's she's
a stage she's a therapist she's
everything you want and the idea was
that was simply
um uh i guess the kindness of strangers
you know it's there anyone can do it
anyone could be
anne in a way but we haven't got time or
we can't be bothered or we think he's a
weirdo
but anyone can be kind anyone i i i i
did a
thing yesterday on my broadcast where it
is like a superpower
if someone says something nice to you it
makes you feel good
nothing else does that except except
beer um
they're the most things that are like
you know monologues they're you know
and when you give you do that and you
worry about it
um and then you sit there and you think
oh this this makes sense is this
a bit longer and then fairly good and
says it
you go i'm gonna get the credit for this
she makes it she makes it she makes it
into poetry
she makes just me going she says
listener it's remark she's remarkable
she's remarkable yeah and before we get
on some audience questions
um you know you talk you you got asked a
lot about the
you know the character and writing it
and stuff and i haven't heard you talk
too much about the fact that you're
actually directing it as well you know
in terms of your
you know that it looks beautiful as well
the way that you've chosen
to make this look aesthetically
is is so lovely and i think adds so much
to
to the feel of it and and how welcoming
it is i think as a show well i think it
it i mean usually i i deal with realism
and the office was meant to be
sort of stark and gritty and faded and
like it was shot on vhs and left at the
bbc
you know that was meant to be like that
it's whatever x was a bit more glamorous
but we showed the difference between
you know a film being made and then the
cold light of day
and this led itself to that because of
what was going on in tony's head and we
were very lucky because
i remember the first time show it was
the best summer of my life
and i thought this is brilliant because
it's beautiful
it's a lovely little you know uh idyllic
sort of middle england uh quaint village
and it's sunny and yet
in there it's dark and i love the
juxtaposition
with that so so it was luck with the
weather
you know you know dolly's shots you put
a little bit more effort into it than
you know but i'm used to fake
documentary as well so
you know things like the office and
derek you know it couldn't look as
beautiful because it was you know what
was in an office what was in the care
home
and there was fake documentary so i i
did push the boat out a little bit on
this
um but again you know technology helps
like the the grade
i think we were the first to use that
that grade and
it's it's beautiful isn't it it's just
you know
not i can't take credit for that it you
know
it was a it was sunny i shot in
hampstead
someone made it look beautiful i can't
take credit
you should mention hawkins as well
because i've worked with him loads over
the years and i've never known a dop be
so good at
translating what a director wants
quickly
he doesn't he's not one of these people
that you're going how long can he go
40 minutes he says things like he goes
like how long he goes 15
i go 12 he goes 13. and we have a joke
we're the fastest we are the fastest
crew
in the world doing this sort of
um high-tech sort of narrative
you know good production um because i
shoot with two cameras when i can as
well so
i save time by getting both sides
of a conversation and particularly with
the emotional ones so
usually you shoot you know two that way
and then turn around but if there's
improv
and someone comes up with someone you
haven't got it on the other side
so if there's any improv and
particularly emotional i strike two
sides
because i want to get their reaction too
so i can cry
and they cry but if we're not facing
them we didn't get them crying properly
because it's harder to do it twice
so it's just things like that you've got
a you've just got to think ahead a
little bit
yeah and then if you thought it because
i
i've got an advantage that i've lived
with this before i direct it
i've written it i've lived with it for
six months so
it's harder for a director to get a
script and think of all those things
i've already thought of them so again
it's it's sort of it's sort of lucky in
the way i work
and another thing about directing like
what's lovely about
being familiar with everybody i've
noticed is that you
you're really intuitive you just get on
with it you don't often stand behind the
uh you don't watch the the screen the
monitor and stuff you go off intuition
so if ricky thinks it's real in real
life and he's watching you
you don't do it again i mean i think i
did the thing when i was doing the
monologue i was thinking okay that's
what
we did one and he went that's brilliant
and then we did one for a lot and he
went nope got it before and that was it
we just did
one and two didn't we i think it's very
quick and it doesn't you seem
for me as well as an actor if i start to
then think about it i become
i i start thinking about it's not
natural and i think that's the beauty of
what
that's it i really make it i really make
it an actor's medium because for me
everything else is not as important as
the performance if you've got a good
script
it doesn't matter whether dolly shots
are the cameras or the symmetry or
whatsoever
you've got to get that performance and
people again people
feel a performance they they don't go
back and go
oh i like the symmetry or i like the
move they go oh my god i was crying when
she was trying
and and i've got to make sure the actors
can do what they want and also
you trust the dop so i set the shot up
and i trust them to do what i've asked
them to do i don't have to keep checking
the monitor
and if they missed it what were they
doing facing the camera the wrong way
and of course they weren't so
when i'm in the scene that's easier for
me to direct than
keep come walking back and forth and
telling two people how to do it because
i can dictate the pace a little bit when
i'm in it i know because i know what i
want
so again it's not all these things that
seem
harder they're easier it's easier to do
everything for me
than to not do what i mean it seems
easier and just put some great questions
coming in just on that emotional side of
things uh jacqueline stevens says ricky
were there any parts that you found
particularly difficult to film because
the subject matter
you cry incredibly convincingly um
i uh yeah i can do that but again
it's got a if it was if the script
wasn't right or i didn't believe it or
it wouldn't make me upset in real life
or the actor wasn't good enough
i wouldn't cry i'd be going this is so
if everything works
i can cry and i can i can cry the first
time
the second time's harder because you
can't fake it as much
so i make sure we get that on the first
tank nearly everything i've ever done
where i've cried has been one take um
and uh there are some things that were
too hard there were some things i didn't
put in actually
um that i thought was too much
originally and this isn't in
originally the thing was going to start
with a little um
a practical joke that went wrong one of
the first thing i had for series 2
where i'm i'm i've set the camera
and i've got a fake spider and i go
i go lisa lisa's coming i'm just going
to put this on a chair she's terrified
of spiders
and uh she comes in she sits down and
she says
i've got cancer and we just
and looking back i thought it was too
much i just thought
we can't start a series like that it was
just
too much um so yeah there are things
that i think
that's that's yeah to just starting like
that so
um i just started something nice
sorry i know you're off just talking
about it
but because we care about we care about
these characters we feel like we know
them that's the thing and we do know
that's the thing and you know what
happens it's not if you start like oh
you can say i hope she gets better but
you know you know
you know the result it's so it's
terrible i love this question
going sorry when we did that little
scene with james where i bring him in
just before the showman was chatting and
we was telling
you know everyone in the office a little
bit of our backstory i toddle off and
i'm sat
watching the monitor and then the next
thing i see ricky
and mandy and i see them crying and i'm
i started crying i was literally sobbing
like
i said to charlie what's happened i
thought
and then i ran on set and i've never
had an expert i keep honestly it was
like projectile crying and they were
both crying and then that was it so i
was like what are you doing he's like
we're just finishing the scene i didn't
know it was coming so you have this kind
of moment and then
and it was it is pretty amazing that's
very very difficult to do it's
impossible
actually so yeah that was uh that was
tough
that was a tough one and it was good
because everyone's so respectful they
know what we're doing and uh
it's as i say it's a it's a great actors
medium because all the time
people are there is acting it's not
seven hours of lighting with someone
sitting in their winnebago and then they
do one shot and they go
okay see you tomorrow we're there for
we're there for seven hours and we're
acting
for seven hours and it's fun it's fun
we're laughing
because none of it's wasted none of it
is wasted
okay i've got a great question from
kelly erlapping who says how did paul
gay react when he read the script for
the second series
the turn in his character is absolutely
incredible
oh my
without the emotional impact of some
characters
that the how we just did those lines
it's like he'd get the man of the match
because
it was filmed in one day it was filmed
in one day okay
and we borrowed a studio from the uh the
film school in beckensfield
and they said uh it was only a little
studio because it was it was the
we built the set and it was a map i'm
not even in this right i'm directing
and they said oh is it okay if a few
students watch and i went yeah sure
right so then he starts doing these
lines
and i'm ruining every tape i'm i'm i'm
just about ten years from and we ruined
every every single day
literally every day i couldn't do it and
i'll go okay do it again
and every time you came up to say it i
went like this right and they all laugh
right at one point i went
okay go again i blocked my ears and shut
my eyes
all right all right and let them finish
and i turned to the students and said
this is not how to direct you shouldn't
direct like this
oh oh amazing it's a great question hugh
collins i want to talk about music which
is such a big part of the show it's just
got uh it gives it
even more of a heartbeat and that's a
combination of the the brilliant score
that you've worked on with andy burrows
but he asks throughout every show you've
created
the musical choices add such a depth to
the story
do you have a specific process when it
comes to this part of the storytelling
no it depends and the short answer is
i've never had a budget like this and
i've never planned music like this
because you can't when you haven't got
the budget for it usually
even in film low budget films are mostly
tv
music is the budget is what's left over
you know the producer go well you can't
afford that one you can have 30 seconds
of that one you can have that which one
do you want okay we love that one
and then you lose live music and it's
just oh yeah
so now i put it in the budget so now i
could pick the best tunes
of my collection and sometimes they come
first
sometimes i go i've always wanted to use
that song that can be a so-and-so
or i'll discover something on a wormhole
down
you know youtube like i discovered um
dave thomas jr on youtube i
i listened to that song um
little piece of nothing for a year and
then i discovered silence halfway
through the filming and i thought oh my
god that'll be the end bit that
so sometimes that comes first and that i
thought i'd motivate a scene oh that
reminds me of so-and-so
and other times you cut the scene you go
what's the perfect song
like some of the end things um so it
depends but it's always been important
to me it's always been
i can't tell people the thrill
of being able to write someone and
direct it and then
choose your favorite music to make it
there's
there's nothing like it and for me the
greatest art form is music
it's there's nothing there's nothing as
a pocket it's
enigmatic i don't know why a chord can
make you feel sick
or make you cry or i just don't i'm in
awe of of music and musicians
as a failed one myself so um all i can
do is put a bit back
and go listen i can put you in my show
now um
so yeah it's very important to me it's
uh it's it's my greatest art form what
do you think
tony you're right well just to add to
that i remember
seeing the um really early drafts of
some of the scripts and you'd actually
written in very specific songs and yeah
i'm in and i think nearly all of those
are in i think one or two
left fell out and got replaced by
something else but yeah they all stayed
in and that's
that means usually you can't do that
because because
they tot it up and they go that's 300
grand
yeah and people go well that's more than
the budget whereas
with this i'd go yeah fine you know it's
someone else's money i can't use the big
songs
you'd get old um bbc videos and dvds
where all of the music had changed
happened to me episodes where yeah quite
specific songs have just gone because
they can't get the right
that happened when they went um when
they when dvds were big because they had
a blanket agreement so you could use the
odd song for 30 seconds
but then when it came to a dvd it was
for the world they went well no
no you can't you can't afford that so
you have to you have to go through and
put lively music in
and if the song is featured or talked
about it makes
no sense at all so
it was the song in season two like about
i don't know
how far in tony when we was watching and
i just burst out crying
it was pre-credits i think i was at top
of the world by um
the carpenters oh my god yeah i've
always i've always wanted to use that
song
and i tried to use it um for invention
of lying
and we we couldn't afford it i don't
know wow
it's one of my favorite songs and i just
went oh no
tony just started laughing at me there
was like three boxes of tissues and we
don't we only watched episode one two
and three in a little room didn't we
what point did you start working with
andy though on the score bits does he
come in at the end when you're doing the
editing or is he part
i did when i knew i wanted to work with
andy because he's just the nicest man in
the world we've talked about it and the
most talented
he can play everything he can do
everything i can
i can download my thoughts through andy
and he does it and i go that's what i
was thinking
it's mental it's it's amazing it's
mental
okay so i found him and that's amazing
and then i started feeding him um
songs over like six months before so i'd
i'd
speed him hammock and you know you know
or things that i go what with this and
uh
you know max richter and i go listen to
this by born williams and
soon when he said it would come back
and i got this but like that and shot
that
and then we went to the studio together
and we started doing it to picture
it was incredible there's a bit um
again nobody in the world will notice
this except me right
but there's a bit where we've done this
some
sort of match richter type thing at the
end of the funeral
and anne comes over and she just touches
my face and we just put a little trim on
the piano
and it was like a disney it's like
it just but people won't notice it but
they'll
yeah they'll feel and
ricky says that luis says ricky what was
the audition process for the wonderful
dog such a lovely relationship between
you
right so i decided i wanted a dog
i thought uh one it was in the script
that the
the high concept joke was not joke but
you know what i mean
that i was going to commit suicide my
dog was hungry and i thought that said a
lot about tony
and everyone really uh and i thought it
was realistic
you know because uh he had to have
nearly done it and then didn't and i
thought why
the dog was hungry perfect reason then
i'll
find a dog i wanted to be a sort of uh
i want to be a big dog because i wanted
to take a walk that'd be boisterous and
to be a bigger a character and then i
think
we went to the one of the people that
did them
and uh i saw andy and i went
you know her um so i admit i did
i did pick one actor
on their looks um but no one else
i don't think that's true
that's not true i did pick tony on his
looks didn't i
um no uh and then i
i met the dog to see if i got on with it
because some dogs
they're just task oriented they don't
they don't acknowledge you they just
they're it doesn't look like it's yours
um and i said to the the uh uh
dad in real life not literally that'll
be mental not a biological father
i didn't want to say owner i'm so i'm so
woke
when it comes to animals
and i said i just wanted to be a dog and
he went oh great
she usually gets parts of like dogs
owned by nazis
right and i went i just wanted to be a
dog it's not disney it's not lassie
i just i don't want any tricks i just
want to be a dog um
and uh i fell in love with her and it
was great
and uh i i don't think there's a better
dog out there for this part
than that yeah so i'm see i'm talking
about her like she's a real actress
he is i i only did one day i think with
when andy when the dog was there all day
and when there was me roshi and joe
wilkinson there
all chatting away when the dog came on
set that we were nothing
ricky was with wayne
what could we do with the dog what i
know
i'm like that i am like i am like when a
dog
sees a ball or a rabbit when i see a dog
that's it
um i've fallen over a few times in
hampton heath when i've seen a dog i
could i wasn't looking where i was going
it's like you know like in in like
comedies where a bloke walks in with
us a nice girl that's me with dogs
well listen we've got a couple more
questions before we run out of time uh
tommy
jessup says how important is the sweden
comedy
um well the swearing
uh is important for uh a few reasons
um again it's real my
my experience of working you know in
real places in real life and real family
and
you know people swear they do and it's
odd
when i see in tv shows when people say
freaking out
or you blow me in here
right i i don't know oh shovel
yeah exactly
there's a film right i think it's called
training day
uh and i was in america and i was in the
gym believe it or not
and it was on it's like two in the
afternoon training day on
on the one of the stairmasters right and
so it was all it was all over dubbed
right
and they were going forget you no you
forgot you right and then he shot him in
the heart
so they weren't allowed to swear but
they learned to shoot someone's lungs
out
where's the morality so swearing's never
bothered me and i make it a part of it
and i think that
it's also nice i like the juxtaposition
because
tony swears when he shouldn't you know
he should you shouldn't call a
10 year old a tubby little ginger you
know
because he is not is you know so it's um
yeah it is used for comedy but it's also
used for realism
well like the fat most foul-mouthed he's
probably carrie's character she
and she has the sweetest scenes and she
yeah the whole
nearly every other line she says
i have to explain i have to explain to
americans that there's
there's a different word here that
doesn't carry the misogyny
we don't use it against women and
sometimes it's a term of endearment
you know you say to you know it really
australians get it brits and australians
use the c word you're a funny
you see you nt and americans go
whoa they they get it
hey i love the bet when he's um it was
so bizarre because you it's he filmed in
borah house so i got married in there
when it's the yoga class
and it's just the way he turns around
and that delivery of that
that particular version of is just so
brilliant
on the money first scene we shot was it
monday morning uh 9 00 am we shot
that scene and um uh with uh seb
cardinal was brilliant
and i just said to be the most annoying
you can
be the most annoying person in the world
while pretending to be zen and caring
that was the that was the direction and
uh
i dressed him i said dressed in like
some like some sort of
guru from the east end right like
wind chimes slurping
oh just i said and i kept going no more
drive me mad
make me go there get me get me really
really annoyed
um so yeah that was uh yeah and also
i'd like the juxtaposition that he was
trying to be zen but someone annoyed him
out of it he couldn't be said
you could try and be saying someone will
annoy you i've tried it
so in a restaurant jay says just ignore
them i'll go yeah you're right
we've done it again we're leaving
and last questions coming from zenith
who says um how long did it take to
shoot the entire second series
uh same as the first um
seven seven five day weeks
finishing up four half four
um and uh finishing early on the last
day because we've
done it all with contingency day so it's
a very luxurious shoe
uh again which is uh partly
financial which is great um and partly
how i shoot and that we workshopped it
and that it's quick and i know we've got
too much
that i never want to be in a position
where i go we haven't shot enough
this episode is going to be 13 minutes
it's never happened
however much i think i have to do less
it still comes in at 40 minutes
um because of the way we work and
because i work with the best people
available there's not a weak performance
in it not only are these people actors
they're writers and they're impropers
and they're directors they're they're
all they're all better than me at
most things and i get all the credit
it's amazing
[Laughter]
um thanks so much for joining us tonight
it's an absolute treat to get to chat to
you about this series because it is
phenomenal and you're a treat to watch
as well
and joel thank you so much love thanks
darling it's lovely to be here thanks
for having me
tony take care mate so lovely to see you
and congratulations thank you so much
bye joe
bye tony ricky thanks so much mate
bye edith good night john boy bye tom
boy good night mary allen
[Laughter]
thanks for joining us and remember you
can listen to previous baptist sessions
and podcasts at guru.bacha.org